look at like addict said I gotta look at
Tango different now
yeah way differently you know what's
crazy this isn't even their primary team
that's why you say you do it I I listen
we when we heard tiger was down we like
yo they got a Japanese Studio that's
dope we know them for what is it even
with the end and you know obviously he's
the legend from Ghost Wire yeah
obviously evil Resident Evil the legend
right so that's the pocket we got them
in you know what I'm saying they come
out and not only this joint
fire like the Polish of this game that
means like Gorilla Games they were
sitting on this sitting on this they
literally had this entire during the
game
even during the game awards they've been
sitting on this game with all the
slander they've been getting no games
you have nothing to talk like and then
it leads me to field interview because
Phil says we already have stuff planned
for now and it's really